i just received this drug calculation
problem from a nursing student and i
think it's essential that the nursing
students out there are able to do this
just in case i'm the patient receiving
the drug so let's do it and i think it's
a it's an interesting unit conversion
problem for pretty much anyone who wants
practice with unit conversion so the
question is that we have a doctor
the doctor orders
orders drug x
drug
x and this is the dosage that the
doctor's requesting they're saying five
milligrams
five milligrams of our drug
per
pound
of patient weight per i'll just write
per pound of patient weight
every 12
hours
this is what we're supposed to do
but our supply of the drug
our supply right here our supply in
green
it isn't just you know it's not just
nuggets in milligrams it's a solution
there's a certain amount of
grams per every milliliter that we have
of the solution it's dissolved in some
maybe probably some water so this is our
supply of drug x
drug x
every we have 0.9
i'll write a zero in front my wife who
is a doctor says it's essential to write
the zero in front of the decimal we have
0.9 grams per milliliter
milliliter of
solution so if i were to take one
milliliter out of my solution and give
it to someone i'm essentially giving
them 0.9 grams of this drug and then the
final piece of information we're given
the final piece of information we're
given is that the patient
the patient
they weigh and maybe we should say they
mass because kilograms is mass but we
get the idea the patient is
72.7 kilograms
72.7
kilograms so there's a couple of
interesting things here we have to
figure out the dosage in terms of
milliliters we have to oh actually i
even tell you the question we have to
say the question is how many milliliters
of solution do we have to give to the
parent per dose to the patient per dose
so milliliters
of solution
per dose
that's our question and there's a couple
of things we have to go from milligrams
to grams and then convert that to
milliliters and then they tell us per
pound but then they gave us the
patient's weight or their mass in
kilograms we have to do some conversion
there so i i definitely can appreciate
how this can be a little daunting and
maybe confusing at times so let's just
do it step by step
so the first interesting thing and this
is just something that you might need to
know or you might have written down on
paper or a you might have a calculator
that does this it's just how to convert
kilograms to pounds and it's good to
know in general if you're converting
between the metric and the english
systems
so one kilogram
is approximately equal to 2.2 pounds not
exactly but that's a pretty good
approximation and one pound if you just
take one over that one pound
is approximately equal to 0.45
0.45 kilograms so we'll just put this in
a box this is the only kind of outside
conversion information we'll need to do
this problem everything else we'll just
need a calculator unless we just want to
spend a lot of time doing some
arithmetic so the first thing let's
let's figure out our dosage in terms of
per kilogram this is per pound and we
really don't need to know every 12 hours
because they're saying how much how many
milliliters of solution do we do per
dose a dose is every 12 hours so we just
really you know every 12 hours is kind
of extra information so we want to
figure out this 5 milligrams per pound
how do we convert that to how many
milligrams per kilogram
so let's do 5 i'll write down here in
magenta
5
milligrams
per
pound
and then we want to convert this to per
kilogram so we could multiply this
times the number of pounds per kilogram
times i'll do it in yellow times this
information right up here times 2.2
pounds
pounds per
kilogram and if you ever get confused
you know gee how did sal know to
multiply by 2.2 instead of dividing by
2.2 which is the same thing as
multiplying by 0.5 you can pay very
close attention to the units
notice i wrote 2.2 pounds per kilogram
2.2 pounds per 1 kilogram and you'll
know this this will work out because you
have a pound in the numerator and you
have a pound in the denominator that's
called dimensional analysis but it's a
very you know if you ever get confused
with these things
and i think when you once you do enough
practice you'll find that you won't have
to pay too much attention to this but at
first when you're getting started just
to make sure you're not you know
multiplying or dividing by the wrong
thing just make sure the dimensions
cancel out pounds in the numerator
pounds in the denominator so let's do
that pounds in the numerator pounds of
the denominator cancel out and you
multiply 5 times 2.2
5 point times 2.2 this is equal to
this is
equal to see 5 times 2 is 10 5 times 0.2
is 1 so this is equal to 11
and then in the numerator we have
milligrams
11
milligrams
per
kilogram
so we've just converted our our dosage
information to a pure metric system it
was actually a mix between the metric
and the english system before now let's
see what we can do well let's see if we
can get it in terms of
how many milliliters we have to deliver
per pound so once again we want this
well actually let's go to grams first
because we have milligrams here we have
grams up here so let's see if we can
convert this thing to grams so just like
we did before we want a milligrams in
the denominator
i'll do it in orange we want a
milligrams in the denominator and we
want a gram in the numerator and why did
i say that because i want this and this
to cancel out i don't want grams in the
numerator so how many grams are there
per milligram and you can just think it
through there's one gram
per thousand
milligrams or 1000 milligrams per gram
and you just multiply it out so the
milligrams cancels with the milligrams
and then we get this is equal to 11
over 1000
grams per kilogram
grams
per kilogram so now we have everything
in terms of grams but we want it in
terms of milliliters the question is how
many milliliters of solution per dose
so let me
go down here on this line right here so
we had what we had this
this result
we have 11 over 1000 i won't do the
division just yet
grams
of hour of drug x per kilogram this is
just this is really just a re uh we've
just rewritten this dosage information
in different units
and let's see how much solution we need
per kilogram
so what i want
i want to cancel out the grams here and
have a milliliters there so to cancel
out that grams i'm going to have to have
a gram in the denominator and a
milliliter in the numerator
and a milliliter
milliliter in the numerator
so in our solution how many
grams are there per milliliter well they
told us there's 0.9 grams per milliliter
or
for every 1 milliliter
there are 0.9
grams
notice i just took the inverse of that
because we want a milliliter in the
numerator grams in the denominator so
that these two cancel out and let's do
this multiplication now so our grams
cancel out we have milliliters per
kilogram
milliliters
per kilogram
and then we multiply it out 11 over 1000
times
1 over 0.9 so i'll just keep let me just
write it like this so this is going to
be 11
over
1000
times 0.9
times 0.9 milliliters of our solution
per kilogram
so we've gotten this far so this is per
kilogram of patient body weight and then
finally they tell us how many kilograms
our patient weighs so let's do that last
multiplication then we can actually get
our calculator out and do it all at once
so let's multiply this times we want to
know how many milliliters per patient we
want the kilograms to cancel out so we
want kilograms
per patient
and we're talking about this particular
patient not every patient is going to be
the same number of kilograms but if we
do this kilograms will cancel out we'll
have milliliters per patient milliliters
of solution per patient which is exactly
what we want we want milliliters of
solution per dose per patient but where
everything we've assumed so far has been
per dose
so how many kilograms does the patient
weigh well there's 72
72.7 kilograms per patient that's how
much the patient weighs so we just do
this final multiplication and we'll be
done so our answer and those these two
things are going to cancel out so our
final answer is going to be 11 times
72.7
divided by
100 times actually 100 times 0.9 is
pretty easy to figure out that's 900
divided by 900
milliliters
per patient or you could just say
milliliters per dose however you want to
say per dose per patient so let's get
our calculator out and do this
so we have 11
times
72.7
is equal to 799
divided by
900 is equal to 0.88 well we could round
up 0.889 hopefully the doctor won't mind
so that is equal to
this is equal to i'll write in a nice
vibrant color
0.889
milliliters of solution of solution per
dose so this is what we're going to give
every 12 hours if they ask how many
total milliliters over the course of two
days we would have to say oh there's 48
hours we'd multiplied by four but that
12 hours was extra information this
problem but anyway hopefully this is
hopeful
this is useful and it will it'll help
ensure that any nurses serving me in the
future are are giving me my proper
dosage and hopefully i got the doctor
even got the right dosage to write to
begin with because otherwise it's all
for naught anyway